alan murray where did you get this idea
to write a book called the wealth of
choices well Brian two things came
together at the same time one was I
recognized that we were in a period of
economic change is really probably more
dramatic than anything we've experienced
in in more than a hundred years since
the Industrial Revolution but the other
thing was I was in a bookstore one day
and I was looking at personal finance
books and flipping through them and I
realized that none of them took him into
account the fact that we were in a
period of such remarkable change they
were basically saying the same things
that they said 20 years ago and it was
so clear to me that this is not my
father's economy that my father's
personal finance advice doesn't work
anymore that there needed to be some new
rules some new suggestions for the new
economy I want to show you and the
audience this is the thing called a quiz
are you ready for the new economy and
you'll notice right next to it there is
the number 150 with a circle around it
that was your score that was my school
it's very good put it on the screen or
yeah what does that mean that means that
that means that you are you're you get
it that that 150 was a passing grade in
my in my calculation say if you score
over 150 points you are off to a good
start score under 50 you'll need to read
this book twice twice so you want most
people not to do well in it all right
well I'd like people to read it at least
once I think there are a few things in
there that they pick up that would be
helpful how many questions you remember
I don't remember you've got let me read
the first okay go last time you do
everybody should take this quiz you say
the last time you bought a car where did
you go first for information a consumer
reports be a car broker see the internet
or D the local car dealer right this is
a this is a perfect example that gets to
the key of the new economy it's all
about information I mean if you think
about it hierarchies have been built on
control of information the powerful
people the elite the lucky ones had
information the rest of us did today
that's all been democratized you have
information and the car buying
experience is a great way to look at how
this has changed because ten years ago
you went to buy
a car you were sitting across from a
Salesman or sales woman who had all the
information and you had very little and
they're talking about rust proofing and
undercoating and and you were pretty
much at their mercy today if you spend
15 20 minutes doing your research and
it's very easy to do on the internet you
go to that car dealer knowing what the
dealer paid for the car of having some
sense of what you're willing to pay for
the car what extras you want what extras
you don't want you go with a lot more
information and that means you have more
power what's a guy who writes and talks
about politics all the time doing
writing a kind of a self-help book on
how to make money well it's an
interesting thing because a lot of
journalists implicit in your question a
lot of journalists may look down their
noses a little bit a kind of self-help
or news you can use we call it and and
and that's really that gets back to what
we were talking about a minute ago I
mean I had spent all this time writing
about the economy thinking about the
economy studying the economy I had never
done anything like this before but it
seemed to me that if if the if it was
clear that the new economy are empowered
people if it was clear that all the new
sources of information the internet and
so forth gave you the power to be on a
par with the elite that that that I
ought to take a stab at writing a book
that showed people how to do that that
just laid out some simple rules here
that said okay here's how you can take
advantage of this new world it's a
totally different world than the world
you and I grew up in and you do have to
sort of have your head up and you do
have to pay attention in order to make
the most of it but anybody can do it
because you allude to in the book i'm
going to ask you what do you think of
Jim Glassman's book Dow 36,000 he SAT
right there and told us all about it
well Jim glassman is a good friend but
I'm not going to hold my breath until
the Dow gets the 36,000 look it's a
remarkable economy we're in its growing
much faster
than anyone even thought was possible a
few years ago remember only five years
ago economist would say that you
couldn't get unemployment below six
percent without causing inflation and
here we are at four percent we've been
there for some time and inflation is not
going up so it's a it's it's clearly a
very different world and that different
world is reflected in higher stock
prices already but to think that we can
get from 10 or 11,000 the 36 thousand
and four years is is I think overdoing
it there's a natural human tendency when
times are good to think that the good
times are going to last indefinitely and
while I think the economy has changed
human nature has what's your full-time
job my full-time job is the Washington
bureau chief for The Wall Street Journal
i coordinate all our coverage out of
Washington we've got as you know we've
got about 40 reporters here in
Washington who cover the waterfront how
long have you done it I've been doing it
for seven years what's the job itself
like a lot of time talking to very
talented reporters about how to focus
stories how to go after stories it's the
nature of the wall street journal
because most of our readers get news
from other sources before they get to us
most of them subscribe to a big Metro
paper most of them may watch you watch
other news on television they may hear
the news on the radio by the time they
get to us they've got the basic who what
when where of the news and what we have
to do is really work on making sure
we're providing some kind of added value
in terms of analysis in terms of the way
we approach a story and so a lot of time
is spent thinking about how you go after
the news and what is the approach we
want to take and what is the analysis we
want to provide and that's what I do one
of the things you point out in the book
is that the Wall Street Journal has done
pretty well with their internet business
compared to the New York Times which is
all ads supported and explain that and
why do you think how many subscribers
does the Wall Street Journal have right
now well we have around 400,000
subscribers
the New York Times claims geez I the
last numbers I saw they were over 78
million registered users but the
difference is in it and it really points
up an interesting facet of the internet
the difference is our subscribers pay
just to to get news over that you
remember how much that it's somewhere
around sixty dollars a year so they pay
we are probably the only news
organization that is actually requiring
people to pay but their 400,000 people
who've been willing to turn over their
credit card numbers and do it the New
York Times is taking more of the
traditional internet approach which is
the key to success on the internet is
getting lots of eyeballs so they're very
proud of the fact that they have these
seven or eight million users although I
have to say I know I personally am at
least eight of those users because every
time I go I register again because I
can't remember my password the idea of
websites like The Times is that by
getting lots of users they will become a
popular place on the internet and they
can eventually monetize that by selling
other services ads ads or whatever so
it's it's two very different models of
how you use the internet ours is much
more traditional you still pay for the
information there's as much more of a
new internet model that you you hope you
you provided free but hope that you can
eventually through advertising and other
means converted into revenue near the
end of your book you say you bought 200
shares of micro strategies you know why
I'm asking you there you must have been
invested in it yourself I did not but
what did you pay for him I bought this
was when I was working on the book I was
doing some research and I I met Mike
sailor who runs microStrategy's struck
me that that was a very interesting
company right on the cutting edge of
where internet businesses were going
because what he does is provide software
that can that can mine these giant
databases and pull up useful information
which is exactly what most Internet
he's now need so and I thought he was a
smart guy so I bought 200 shares of
stock at thirty dollars apiece and five
months later they had split so I had 400
shares of stock and they were worth
three hundred dollars a piece for a very
brief time and today I don't know what
is today but they went down to 21 yeah
today they're pretty much back down to
where they were when I bought them last
August what does that say about the new
economy I think it tells you a couple of
things one is that even though we are in
a revolutionary economic period it
doesn't justify ridiculous stock values
MicroStrategy stock never had any
business being at three hundred dollars
a share although i'm happy to say i sold
some of my shares at that price so i
think that the enthusiasm about the new
economy clearly got out of hand in some
of these stock prices that you saw what
do you think about i know one of your
chapters and ears on privacy and people
constantly need help to say i'm tired of
getting those phone calls at seven
o'clock at night pitching me something
right in the middle of dream what do you
do about this well as you know I in the
book I suggest several steps that you
can take to protect yourself from from
those concerns but i think it's a big
issue and i think it's going to be a an
issue that Congress is going to have to
deal with in the next couple of years
but what mountain well a couple of
things you can do on the telephone calls
you can actually write to the Direct
Marketing Association I have the address
in the book you can ask that you be
taken off the list when you get a call
you can also demand that you be taken
off there call list in most cases they
are required by law to do so when you
ask but then there's some other very
simple things you can do that I suggest
in the book for instance to protect your
privacy more generally for instance when
you buy a new product you get a product
registration card you're made to feel
like you better fill that card out or
something bad will happen well the truth
is that's just one more method of data
collection by the company if you don't
want them to have that data
just don't fill it out don't send the
car did and there are a number a number
of other there are a couple of services
one provided by a company called
anonymizer that can help you protect
yourself on the web there are a lot of
things you can do but I think ultimately
that there's probably going to have to
be some some legislation as well now you
brought some of your friends in on this
I mean Ken bacon is the spokesman over
at the Pentagon we now know what he made
on a house how did you do that and tell
me why did you do well one of the
reasons I wrote this book was because
this new economy that we are in
developed over the last 20 years a
period during which i was spending my
time writing about researching thinking
about the economy and I decided the best
way to describe what had happened over
the last 20 years was to was to use my
own experiences over that period the
people i had met i had interviewed or
people who I just knew friends who would
who would who had lived through some of
that so it is a very personal book which
made it fun for me to write I hope makes
it fun to read as well did you have to
get can bake information oh yeah sure I
talked to Ken okay what did you tell us
about ken bacon well Ken one of the
points I make in the book one of the
things that is different today about the
world that many of us grew up in is the
lack of inflation if you pick up almost
any personal finance book on the shelves
today and go to the section on home
mortgages it will tell you get a big
home mortgage you know mortgage get the
biggest mortgage you can carry because
it's a great deal because you get to
write off the interest well in fact that
was good advice 10-15 years ago when
inflation was running at high rates
because inflation boosted the value of
the house at the same time you got to
write off the interest on your taxes and
I used Ken bacon as as an example of
that he bought a house in in Washington
in the early 1970s and watched over that
period of inflation watched this
remarkable rise in the value of that
house which which
made the the mortgage justified many
times over that's not the world we live
in today it's a very different world you
have to think about home buying
differently you can't assume that
inflation is going to bail you out the
way it did in the 70s and even in the
80s you tell us your wife used to work
for Nancy Kassebaum mm-hmm eight years
she worked for names what'd she do for
she was her foreign policy advisor did
all her foreign policy work was the only
person on Nancy Kassebaum staff who
didn't come from the state of Kansas but
she didn't she didn't tell too many of
the constituents that where did you meet
her your why I met her here and then
that led to Nancy Kassebaum inviting you
to speak to a group there was a I tell
the story in the book of speaking to the
US Turkish Business Council and it was a
witch Nancy Kassebaum asked me to speak
to this was about a year and a half ago
I showed up at this dinner or about 600
people there and it was probably the
noisiest dinner I had ever been at and
when the master of ceremony started to
speak the people at the dinner continued
to talk and Clank their dishes and I
thought oh my gosh what have I gotten
myself into but then I stood up and I
started to talk about this new economy
and and how it had changed so much from
10 or 15 years ago and I used the
metaphor of the Istanbul bizarre have
you ever been at the bazaar at Istanbul
I mean in a way that's what the world
has become it's become a global version
of that bazaar where you have this
wonderful cornucopia of of goods and
services available to you and you have
the power to choose you have to haggle
you have to take care of yourself you
can't assume that the person who's
selling you something is going to give
you a good price but if you don't like
the price you can step to the next booth
and find somebody else to tell it to
sell it to you and that's what the words
become like just let me give you one
little example it is remarkable one of
the things i learned researching this
book is that prices in today's world are
no longer fixed anywhere you walk into a
store on this
here in Washington they know that the
the watches they sell are the cameras
they sell are available on the internet
at much lower prices and if you push
them more often than not they will
negotiate with you that's a big change
from 10 years ago or 15 years ago hotels
if you go into a hotel you should just
make it a practice to always say when
they tell you that the room rates $150
say hey can't you give me a better rate
than that don't you have some sort of a
better deal more often than not they
will be able to come up with some sort
of a discount or some sort of a special
program you you qualify for the key for
businesses in this new economy is price
discrimination you get the most you can
get from people who are willing to pay
but if people insist on a bargain you
give it to them because you know they
have choices you know they can go
someplace else and find somebody who
will who will sell to them at that lower
price has all this changed journalism it
has it changed the way journalists
themselves live with all this ocean air
they more interested in money than they
used to be oh well I was probably
probably so I mean what one of the
what's happened here is that more and
more aspects of our lives have been
subject to the marketplace the
marketplace permeates everything even
things like health care health care did
health care services did not used to be
something you consumed you simply went
to your doctor your doctor told you what
was wrong you did what he or she told
you to today you you make choices about
what health plan you're going to be in
if you're going to have a major
operation you should research the
hospital hospitals so all of us have
been forced to become much more
conscious of the marketplace because it
affects so many more parts of our lives
but you asked about journalists I mean
you're a great example of this look at
television you know when when I was
growing up when I was growing up you had
the the mean the choice in television
was VHF or uhf that was pretty much it
now you have all these cable channels
they give you
a much wider variety of choice many more
ways to receive your news whether you
want to receive it from a radio radio
talk shows television whether you want
to experience the the debate on the
floor of the House of Representatives
first hand through c-span it's just a
multiplication of the choices you have
as an individual and that's a metaphor
for what's happened in every area what
year did you well first of all what
towns you grow up in I grew up in in
Tennessee on Lookout Mountain look at
Mountain Kennedy uh-huh right outside of
chattanooga and what were your parents
doing then my father at that time was a
he moved to worked for Westinghouse for
many years moved to Chattanooga as a
sales representative for Westinghouse
left his job and went into business for
himself as a industrial representative
of selling electrical goods to big
utility companies and your mom she was
not working when I was young but then
went later went back to work as a as a
teacher a guidance counselor in the city
schools which something she still does
is your father's to a lot no my father
died two years ago you mentioned your
brotherly in the book where is he he's
in Tennessee as well he works for the
Chamber of Commerce in Chattanooga and
you left Chattanooga what early 70s to
go to university north carolina that's
right why why why not Carolina I
actually went to North Carolina because
there's a wonderful scholarship program
called the Morehead scholarship that
that takes people to the University of
North Carolina on a full scholarship
it's a wonderful program set up by John
Motley Morehead designed to attract
people's the University of North
Carolina and that was enough to to get
me there study what I studied English
literature didn't study any economics as
an undergraduate at all justjust
literature what year did you get out of
UNC 1977 then did what then I went back
to Chattanooga and worked for the
Chattanooga time
for a couple of years before going off
to graduate school then in economics who
owned the times it was owned by the the
salts burger family which is the family
that also owns the New York Times wasn't
actually owned by the new york times
company but takes great pride or took
great pride in the fact that it was the
parent paper of the New York Times
Adolph Fox back in the in the 19th
century ran the Chattanooga Times then
left Chattanooga moved to New York
bought the New York Times and
refashioned it in the model of the
Chattanooga paper do you remember what
your education costs you back then well
it didn't cost me anything thanks to
John motley Moorhead what would I have
gone uh but out-of-state tuition at the
University of North Carolina then was
maybe a couple thousand dollars a years
you refer to one school on here that
today would I think you put a figure
something like sixty five thousand
dollars a year that it would cost for
everything it's it's a huge expense and
it's a real paradox one of the things
that's clear about this new economy is
that education and knowledge are more
valuable than ever before the returns to
education if you're if you're a woman in
today's society for instance with a
college education you will on average
make double what women without college
education makes it's an enormous
difference bigger than it's ever been
before and so you cannot you cannot go
wrong by investing in your own education
but having said that it's not easy to
come up with sixty five thousand dollars
a year to put yourself or your children
through college and so I devote a
substantial part of that book I have a
chapter in the book about some of the
new new methods that are available to
try and help finance that Amanda and
lucy-ann your daughters are held they
are eight and ten any because you
discussed it in there are you doing
anything for their college education now
I have saving savings accounts for both
of them which I contribute to I
contribute to regularly what are your
options if you're a parent well one of
the most interesting new
and I think this will be expanding in
the years to come are these tax
preferred state savings accounts a lot
of states have them you can put money
into an account in some cases the
account is run by fidelity or a big
investment house can put money in it you
can escape state taxes and you can save
towards tuition at any college in the
state very attractive very attractive
programs and there's some talk in
Congress as I'm sure you know about
expanding those so they also apply to
private schools as well so I think I
think one of the things that we are
likely to see happen over the next few
years is an expansion of these tax
preferred savings accounts for education
precisely because it's so expensive on
the one hand but so important on the
other three women in your family and you
oh well and that's you're not counting
the dog and the turtle the dog is
definitely female the turtle i assume is
a female although i haven't quite
figured out how you what are your
daughter's like what did what what are
they different in any way oh yeah
they're there they are are both
voracious readers they look they look a
lot alike but they are remarkably
different in some other ways there what
is your wife doing now she's doing some
consulting with the Pentagon but mostly
is at home home at home with the kids
are your daughters on the internet my
oldest daughter particularly likes to
send email to her friends and they spend
some time on the on the internet we
don't encourage them to spend a lot of
time on the internet I mean one of the
one of the and I have a chapter about
this in the book as well I mean one of
the problems with the internet is that
it's totally unfiltered unscreened I
mean there's a lot of stuff out there
that you really don't want to expose
little kids to now there's some there's
some ways to deal with that America
Online has a very good family friendly
filter that you can use and there's some
other methods of doing that as well as
you sit here today and think about the
book and and the internet and all this
new economy does the government have a
role
apply is your things you think need to
be done by the Congress by the president
yeah in fact one of the things when
you're dealing with an issue like
privacy for instance you realize that it
has to be dealt with in Washington it
it's an issue that cannot be dealt with
by the individual businesses because the
whole the whole problem is is not
dealing with the vast majority of firms
that you know we're going to act to
respect your privacy but how you deal
with the outlier it can't be dealt dealt
with on a state-by-state basis because
you're talking about a world where
information is just flowing across state
borders and really even national borders
so at a phenomenal rate so privacy is an
example of the kind of issue that's
going to have to be sorted out in in
Washington I think the taxation issue is
another one as you know it's an issue
over whether you collect sales taxes
over the Internet eventually states
either have to be able to collect sales
taxes over the internet or they'll have
to come up with a new way of financing
themselves maybe property taxes or
income taxes or something if we are
going to collect sales taxes over the
internet then there has to be some sort
of national standard because you can't
expect little internet companies to deal
with 50 different state tax regimes so I
think you can see a number of places
where the new economy is posing big
policy issues for Washington after the
Chattanooga Times you went where and
what year well I I went to graduate
school at the London School of Economics
in 1979 and got my master's degree in
economics there is there a philosophy
that they teach you a political
philosophy at the London School well it
was it I was there at an interesting
time because the economics program
itself has traditionally been a pretty
conservative program it was the it was
the antidote to Cannes at Cambridge this
was sort of classical economics but
surrounding that economics program is a
very active political program which is
was then very left-leaning and among
many of students really
radical you know I came from the
University of North Carolina where which
is a very social school a lot of clubs a
lot of fraternities clubs where people
got together for a good time at the
London School of Economics there was
something like 50 clubs all of them
political and they started the most
conservative was a Labour Party club and
then they shot off to the left from
there there were there were I saw the
signs in the hallways of three groups
that would gather each year to celebrate
Stalin's birthday and there was another
group that was devoted to the
recognition of Albania so it was a
politically very radical charged place
but in the midst of all that tournament
was this economics program that was
based in classical pre Keynesian
economics what impacted all that have on
you oh well it was a very difficult year
and a very rigorous education in
classical economics and and it's really
where I began to understand the
extraordinary power of the marketplace
how markets can be applied to deal with
many different human situations and
where was Margaret Thatcher when you
were over there Margaret Thatcher just
taken over she wasn't very popular at
the London School of Economics because
she had cut a lot of the subsidies a lot
of the subsidies to the schools and I
don't think anyone at that point
understood the degree to which she was
the front end of this revolution that
we're talking about it was really
Margaret Thatcher's policies followed by
Ronald Reagan that that put into place
the kind of market oriented policies
that allowed this economic revolution to
take place and in 79 year old I would
have been about 24 so you have your
masters from London School of Economics
and then you went where I came back here
to Washington and went to work for the
Congressional quarterly covering
Congress what's your goal at that point
I was in I was interested in journalism
was planning to stay in journalism was
interested in in writing about
makes the economy and how the economy
effected affected people I don't think I
quite had it in my head that the wall
street journal was the only place to be
but I had certainly thought about it did
you have an economic point of view at
that point I don't think so don't think
I had a strong economic point of view I
was certainly interested in economics as
a way of looking at social issues and
social problems I didn't come at this as
a business reporter was not that was not
first and foremost my interest i was
interested in how markets and economics
could be used to affect society and
living standards and people you named
the number one person in this town for a
good quote in the economics world back
there when you were reported the number
one person in town for a good quote it
was not Alan Greenspan well no you said
that he was always the beat it was he
was the man to talk to I talked to Alan
Greenspan all the time for wisdom that's
what I made for wisdom what was he doing
that he was he had his own consulting
firm uh Townsend Greenspan and I when I
first joined the wall street journal
which would have been in 1983 I had to
write all the little economic reports
that came out of the government durable
goods went up consumer spending went
down and I was handed a list of
economists to call to talk to him to get
quotes and what I discovered was most of
them were very ready and willing to give
me a quick quote if that's what I needed
but if I was really confused about what
was going on in the economy Alan
Greenspan by far was the best person to
go to by the way where did you get this
picture taken it was in New York got a
long session at a studio I don't know if
you've ever been through one of those
photography sessions but it was an
unusual experience and back today the
alan greenspan days did you know at the
time that he would play such a role in
the country no no I had no idea I mean
he of course I'd already been the
chairman of the of President Ford's
Council of Economic
Pfizer's and he was even then a very
close advisor to to the Reagan
administration was frequently brought in
to discuss policy issues and so forth
but I I did know certainly didn't know
that he was going to become chairman of
the Federal Reserve and I don't think
anyone then could have imagined the
remarkable period of economic growth
that his chairmanship would bring about
I mean remember remember Brian you know
ten years ago we were reading books like
Paul Kennedy's the rise and fall of
great nations that was predicting that
the United States was on the backside of
the power curve that we were somehow in
an inevitable period of decline and the
Japan was going to take our place there
was another book called Japan as number
one or later people would say China was
going to be the economic powerhouse of
the next century well here we are in the
next century and it's clear more than
ever before that the rest of the world
is looking to us to see where the
economy of the future is going what's
the difference between what we did as a
country and what the others did I think
it was an it was a understanding or a
system that allowed not just for
technological development but for
entrepreneurship that allowed for
individual human beings to develop ideas
into businesses that's really the
hallmark of the American economy and
that's a that's a neat thing I mean
think about all the science fiction that
has been written over the last two
centuries suggesting that technology was
going to somehow be dehumanizing I
reread not long ago brave new world by
Huxley or fair and remember the movie
Fahrenheit 451 1984 by orwell all the
all this fiction which suggested that
somehow technology was going to
dehumanize us that we were going to
become slaves to technology that it was
going to become the mechanism by which
human beings are devalued instead what's
happened is the
act opposite we live in a world where
the thing of highest value is a creative
supple human intelligence where a smart
person with a good idea can go out in
this country and raise millions of
dollars to create a new business that's
what Silicon Valley is all about that's
that's a very exciting a very exciting
thing and that's what we have you say in
the book that you got to know our become
friends with janet yellen and joseph
stiglitz and Larry Summers how did that
happen more the circumstance when I was
at the wall street journal in in the
mid-1980s one of my editors said that we
needed to write more about academic
economist and that I should go out and
find a story to do on academic
economists and so I talked to people in
economics people i knew i said point me
to the the best and the brightest you
know the young the rising young stars
and those were were three of the people
who i ended up talking to and doing a
front-page story on and they are Larry
Summers is now the secretary of the
Treasury in the Clinton administration
Janet Yellen was head of the council of
economic advisers and Joe Stiglitz
recently left his job as chief economist
for the World Bank none of them were
involved in public policy at the time
but all of them have gotten involved
since on the surface a an alan greenspan
in the larry summers and the janet
yellen and the Joe Stiglitz would be on
opposite sides certainly opposite sized
him to Milton Friedman's you talk about
in your book a little bit what's
happened over the years to their theory
of economics I I think one of the things
that's happened over the last 20 years
is that all economist and all people
really have come to recognize the power
of free markets you go back to the 1970s
and there was really still some
ambivalence about our economic system
versus say the Soviet economic system I
read in working on this book I read john
kenneth galbraith book
I'm having elapsed here Brian what's the
new industrial the new industrial state
which was one of the most important
books of the 1960s 1970s widely read
widely quoted and it's and it's
interesting to see what Galbraith argues
in that book he argues that that there
really isn't a huge wasn't a huge
difference between the American economy
and the Soviet economy that the Soviet
economy was a centrally planned
government-run economy but that the
American economy he argued had become a
corporate planned economy that big
companies like Ford would decide what
cars they were going to produce would
put them into train years in advance and
then would advertise in order to make
sure that the consumer demand was there
for the cars that they wanted to buy and
he said over time we're going to
recognize that these two things are
really very similar and that there'll be
some sort of a new synthesis well it was
a persuasive thesis at the time in
retrospect it looks ridiculous that's
not what happened at all what happened
was that that the American economy
developed into a much more supple much
more of a real market economy you know
today today the the the signals that go
back and forth between the consumer and
the producer have become so
sophisticated this shirt I have on is a
good example I designed this shirt
myself I went on the internet a place
called shirt creations com I told them
what kind of fabric I liked I told them
what kind of tough I like what kind of
collar I like I put in my exact
measurements and they made the shirt to
order for me that kind of power for the
consumer is good we're going to be doing
that with cars soon where you will go
directly to forward and you'll say this
is the car I want and these are the
options i want and these are the options
i don't want and they will make your car
for you that capability exists today so
so instead of moving towards a kind of a
cumbersome centrally planned economy
which is what Galbraith imagined
what has happened is that we've we've
we've done Adam Smith one better we've
become a much more supple sophisticated
flexible market where consumers really
can say this is what I want this is what
I'm willing to pay and they get it one
of the things you do in your book is
named places like shirt creations com
and other websites where people can go
and order things do you think that
through you're worried about putting
your name and kind of em promoter on
those organizations well I was very
careful in who i saw and who I selected
to put to put in the book one of the
problems of this information rich
society we live in is that not all
information is created equal that
there's good information and there's bad
information and I site in the book a
place called the National Vaccine
Information Center which sounds like a
government site sounds you know if you
go there it looks like a very solid
respectable site but in fact it was
created by a group of people who whose
children had adverse reactions to
childhood vaccinations and who are now
in a campaign to convince people not to
have their kids vaccinated and what what
of course you won't find anywhere on
that site is is the fact that the vast
majority of doctors in today's world
believe the facts that book that the
benefits of vaccination far outweigh the
costs so there's sites like that that
are clearly designed to misinform and
you do have to be careful where you get
your information from and and I think I
was pretty careful in deciding which
places to put in the book who do you
thinks the best kind of person to read a
book like this this book is it there are
a lot of books that have been written
for the experts okay the professional
and new economy investor the businessman
this book is not for the expert this
book is for the average person out there
who understands that something
revolutionary is happening in our
economy and wants to know what it is and
wants to know how to take advantage of
it
there's a bunch of on the back some
blurbs complimenting you on your book
one of them comes from Dave Gardner of
The Motley Fool you say some nice things
in there about the Motley Fool tell her
story what came first the story or the
blurb oh the the story came first all
those blurbs came after the book was
completed and I sent him out to those
people and asked him if they had
something they'd be willing to say
what's the motley full story Miley fool
is a good example of the new economy
because they're what what they they're
an investment service online but what
they are saying is you don't need a
broker you don't need a you don't need
to a highly paid money manager or mutual
fund manager to handle your money that
you can do it yourself and it's not that
hard it doesn't take that much effort
you just need to follow a few simple
rules and that's really what their
service is all about and that's also
more broadly the point I make in this
book where did they come from they came
from well David Gardner who was the one
of the gardener brothers I knew also
went to the University of North Carolina
although about 10 years after i did and
when he first started this business it
was a newsletter which he sent
unsolicited to a number of people
including me and so I saw the the
original Motley Fool newsletters which
were a combination of humor criticism
and investment advice but then they
discovered very quickly that they could
take it online and made a deal with
America Online and and the rest of it is
history there a very successful online
investment service and a good one too
what book is this for you this is my
second the first one first one is a book
called showdown at Gucci Gulch which is
the story of the 1986 tax act and a look
at how Congress operates or at least
operated in 1986 is that book still
selling it's still selling quite well in
university bookstores mostly a lot of
political science professors use it as
an introduction to the legislative
process what's changed in those all
those years Oh a lots changed
most of the of course most of the tax
reform act itself has been undone in the
14 years since then but I guess the
biggest and most disturbing change has
been the way that partisanship has taken
over everything in this in Washington
you know in 1986 you had strong
partisans involved in the debate Ronald
Reagan was president the Democrats
controlled the house of representative
Dan Rostenkowski was the head of the
Ways and Means Committee but you had a
bunch of people working at the staff
level who were actually always trying to
bring those extremes together to a
middle ground solution and you had an
amazing degree of comedy between Dan
Rostenkowski and Ronald Reagan and
Ronald Reagan's people and a lot of
that's broken down since then it's
become a much much more partisan place
Republican staffs don't talk regularly
to Democratic staffs I mean you know
this better than I do you watch it day
after day after day but it's very
different it's a very different city
than it was in 1986 do you have any
sense and this is not an endorsement of
one side of the other I'm looking for
but any sense of which individual george
w bush or Al Gore would be better for
partisanship in the town if you listen
to these two men george w bush talks a
lot more about the need to get over
partisanship the need to find bipartisan
solutions to the need to change the
culture of washington now some of that
is because he's the outsider it's a
little difficult for Al Gore to talk
about changing the culture of Washington
since he's been so much a part of that
culture for the last 20 years but at
least in their rhetoric George Bush is
talking more about returning to an era
of more comedy and more bipartisan
cooperation so going back to your book
if somebody to buy this book you know
take a which i recommend yeah I know but
take a couple minutes to tell tell tell
the eyes what's in it that will be of
use to them other than your views on the
world it's two things first of all
fairly compact easy to read explanation
of what the new economy is and how we
got here but then second are some very
basic rules of the road that help you
operate in that economy whether you're
talking about buying a nation healthcare
buying a car or a digital camera saving
for retirement it addresses all those
issues one by one and says here's how
the rules have changed it's a new
economy you need new rules here they are
but there are a lot of lists a lot of
lists was that an idea that may need you
think about that specifically to make it
easier well I talked it through with the
publisher and and we felt that that was
what people were looking for if you're
if you were facing a major medical
procedure you can go to this book and
and say okay here the eight questions
you need to ask yourself to make sure
you're making the right choice if you
are as a consumer you know trying to
decide whether you're you're being taken
advantage of or not in this new economy
you know seven or eight simple questions
you can ask yourself before making a
major purchase that helped you know that
you were doing the right thing go down
at choices are a number of things that
you talk about what would you recommend
on retirement retirement the main thing
you have to remember is that we are
living longer than ever before and as a
result you have to be prepared for a
much longer retirement what does that
mean means first of all you got to say
if you can't count on Social Security
alone and you should take advantage of
every tax preferred savings vehicle that
is available to you amazing how few
people do that Brian if if somebody
walks up to you on the street and offers
you five hundred dollars the correct
answer is yes thank you very much I'll
take that well the same thing is
happening in the world of savings and
it's it's almost criminal the number of
people who aren't taking advantage of
those savings opportunities which you
will need when you retire when you talk
about education
say that five and half million people
are in community colleges community call
that what our community colleges in the
new economy community colleges are
actually one of the most interesting
areas of the new economy because in many
communities they have worked closely
with the local businesses to try and
figure out what are the skill sets that
are most valued by those businesses
they're more responsive to the
marketplace and so a lot of times
community colleges can be a wonderful
place to to improve improve your skills
and by the way Brian that is one of the
I talked about improving your skills one
of the key points this is in chapter 8
of this book is that you really have to
change the way you think about your
career that in the new economy you
constantly have to be working on
upgrading your skills upgrading your
attractiveness upgrading your value in
in the marketplace buying stocks what
would you do buying stocks first of all
it depends on how much time and energy
you want to invest in it if you don't
want to invest a lot of time and energy
stock index funds are a good way to go
more often than not you'll do better
than the money managers by doing that
what about savings you have some figures
in here about our little American say
it's their astonishing figures and I
also provide a link to smart money calm
which has a little savings account a
little savings calculator that can help
you figure out how much you need to save
to achieve your goals in retirement when
you wrote this there were 250
billionaire's I've seen a list somewhere
there's over 300 billionaire's the
United States and four million
millionaires in 1998 what impact does
that have on everything a an amazing
creation of wealth in a very in a very
short time and one of the disturbing
aspects of the new economy I believe
strongly on balance that the new economy
is a good thing for the vast majority of
people but one of the disturbing aspects
as there has been a growing gap between
the rich and the poor both in this
country and worldwide rich nations and
poor nations
her farther apart than they were 20 or
30 years ago I don't think that has to
be so I think there's some signs that
it's starting to turn around in this
country but I think it is one of the
very disturbing side effects of what's
been going on for the last couple did
you change your mind about anything
during this writing of this book about
how you live your own life oh yeah oh
yeah I changed a lot of things as I told
you earlier one of the things that I
wasn't prepared for was the degree to
which all prices have gone flexible in
this economy that you never pay the
sticker price I didn't know that I
wasn't aware that and it has changed
that has certainly changed the way I
operate I'm also increasingly convinced
that the value of spending just a little
bit of time using the Internet to do
research before making any kind of a
major purchase or an investment decision
just an awful lot of information out out
there that can be incredibly useful
early in your career you took two trips
at least two he took three basically
went 1-2 Russia 12 pole and one to Japan
what did what were those about well the
Russian trip I went right after the
collapse of the Communist Party and you
know I grew up at a time when we were
still doing civil defense drills under
our desks in elementary school because
of the fear of the Russians and it was
an amazing thing to see what a basket
case the centrally planned Russian
economy was to realize what a total
failure this system had ultimately
provided there was a joke in Moscow at
the time I was there about the guy whose
car broke down and he needed a new car
and he so he called up and they said yes
sir we can bring you a car but it'll be
on May the fifth in the year two
thousand and four and the guy says well
could you make it in the afternoon i
have a plumber coming that morning it
was sort of a sign of just the total
collapse of that economy the japanese
experience was very different again
remember 10 years ago there was a sense
that maybe the Japanese had found the
third
way that maybe the Japanese had
discovered how you combine the ability
of the government to direct an economy
with the power of the marketplace in
order to do something better than a more
market-oriented system like ours could
do hold up Pollan and and of course let
me just say in the end it turned out to
be wrong the Japanese economy collapsed
and the asian model was largely
discredited in the late 1990s poland i
was at polling at the time when poland
was again trying to figure out how you
take an economy that had been run as a
communist centrally planned economy for
four decades and turn it into a
capitalist economy and i thought before
i went there that the polls might be
looking for a third way as well maybe
there was some kind of a swedish model
that combined the the power of the
marketplace with some sort of more
directed government role but in fact i
got there bowser oh it was as finance
minister was leading the reform charge
and he said quite bluntly to this
delegation of American government
officials there is no third way and
we're not interested in experimenting
with a third way we want capitalism what
is your hunch everything that goes EPS
got to come down so this thing I'm going
to go on forever here in the United
States or is it no no it won't go on
forever I mean I the market system has
proven itself to be more powerful and
more beneficial than any of the
alternatives but that doesn't mean it's
perfect what's your hunch though that
somebody will do what will happen to
change it I think what is what may
happen is that you begin to see the kind
of reaction that you're seeing just the
very big little stirrings of in the
protests that went on at the Democratic
convention in los angeles or at the
republican convention in philadelphia or
at the WTO meeting in seattle people
saying hey folks there are important
things out there whether it's the
environment
or whether it's human values that can't
be subjected to the marketplace and say
don't take this marketplace stuff too
far every action has its reaction and I
think in those protests you're seeing
the very beginnings of a reaction to
this intense market focus that we are
now now living in but but but boy right
now it's just very nascent to new and
most people are just coming to grips
with the the enormous benefits that this
new economy is providing in the back you
book and the you thank you a lot of
people but keith is it perrine pari pari
you said wrote a considerable part of
this book yeah he was my research
assistant worked on this for for about a
year did a lot of the research did
initial drafts of several of the
chapters he now works for the industry
standard he's a reporter for the
industry standard but he's very very
smart man and who is the Neil Freeman
that taught you the difference from the
big picture and Neil Freeman has litical
a television producer who put together a
show in the late 1980s that I was
involved in called money politics that
was a talk show an effort to deal with
economic issues that arose in Washington
and he was really the first person who I
talked to about trying to to get across
this barrier between those of us in
journalism who wrote about the big
picture and those who provided useful
advice the news you could use that
there's no reason for there to be such a
gulf between those two types of
journalism you ought to be able to do
both in one place as I've attempted to
do in this book where can we see your
writing now well I write I write every
month for Smart Money Magazine I have a
column that I co-author with al hunt and
I do the outlook column in The Wall
Street Journal periodically every couple
of months or so but but I spend most of
my time an awful lot of my time
managing rather than writing and when
can we see on television I am on CNBC
twice a day 6 15 in the morning and 1050
in the morning and then I also regularly
on PBS's Washington we can review on
Friday evenings at eight o'clock and to
do the 615 in the morning on CNBC what
time do you get up well i get up at
about five normally when i was out in
los angeles at the democratic convention
i was getting up at two because of the
time change but i usually get up at
about 5 i'm able to go to a studio the
NBC studio is just 10 minutes from my
house so I go there and I do my morning
spot and then I go home and get my
little girls up and take them to school
and going to write another book I'm not
going to do it right away it's a it's a
lot of work to do that and do a full
time job at the same time but but but
I'm sure someday I will it's fun it's a
nice a nice opportunity Washington
bureau chief The Wall Street Journal
alan murray our guests the book is
called the wealth of choices thank you
very much thank you Brian